[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reporteros gracias por acompañarnos
comenzamos es considerada por muchos
como la gota que rebasó la copa el
pasado 4 de enero insurgentes de la
división afgano-paquistaní del
autodenominado estado islámico
asesinaron a 10 trabajadores hazara en
una mina de carbón ubicada a unos 60
kilómetros de la ciudad de queta capital
de la provincia paquistaní de
baluchistán se trata de una región
inestable a la que no pueden acceder los
extranjeros y desde donde llegan muy
pocas noticias sobre la situación de
inseguridad terrorismo y la insurrección
interna no es la primera vez que la
minoría chiíta se ve afectada por la
violencia pero en esta oportunidad no
pudo contener más su ira
por este motivo miles de personas se
reunieron inquieta y para mostrar su
rechazo se negaron a enterrar los
cuerpos de sus familiares para así
llamar la atención del primer ministro y
exigir protección del estado la minoría
hazara representa el 20 por ciento del
total de la población de afganistán
tanto en este país como en el vecino
pakistán la minoría chiíta es blanco de
discriminación y día
ataques terroristas por parte de
islamistas radicales los chiítas hazara
son objeto frecuente de los ataques de
los extremistas sunís esta es la
historia
[Música]
ira y de su esperanza en las calles de
que está la temperatura es inferior a 6
grados en enero estos miles de azahara
chiítas inicia en su cuarto día de
plantón desde la masacre de 10 obreros
de una mina de carbón perpetrada por el
autodenominado grupo de estado islámico
hussein ali grita a la gente
[Aplausos]
en duelo la comunidad ahora se refiere a
él
hussein ali nieto del profeta mahoma que
fue decapitado en el 680 en kerbalá irak
es el símbolo del mártir para los
chiítas en estos penetró reposan los
cuerpos de las víctimas
[Música]
entre ellas el padre y el hermano de
esta joven mujer
y trabajaban en la mina de carbón se
ganaban la vida era de noche estaban
durmiendo unos terroristas llegaron y
los vendaron los ojos les amarraron las
manos en la espalda les dispararon y los
decapitaron con un cuchillo
[Música]
tuvimos que cavar una fosa común señor
primer ministro por el amor de dios haga
justicia estamos sentados en este frío
desde hace cinco noches por favor haga
justicia es frecuente que los chiítas
sean tomados como blanco en esta
provincia de baluchistán la más
peligrosa de pakistán lo como el grupo
estado islámico y los talibán están
establecidos en la región así como otros
grupos terroristas sunitas hacemos una
pausa para la oración y luego les damos
una palabra a los que quieren día cad
armap ali es uno de los organizadores de
esta manifestación perdón perdón
son los 11 cuerpos de los mártires que
fueron asesinados con brutalidad en las
fotos puede ver que todos eran jóvenes
hubo cinco personas de una misma familia
que fueron asesinadas y perdí un hermano
tiempo atrás amigos parientes conozco el
dolor de perder a alguien pero otro
nivel de brutalidad ha sido alcanzado
con estos mártires porque fueron
masacrados
el primer ministro pakistaní fue
finalmente a que está más de una semana
después del ataque para presentar sus
condolencias a las familias de las
víctimas
[Música]
en afganistán la esperanza también está
cayendo en la comunidad azahara como en
pakistán la minoría chiita con
frecuencia es blanco de ataques el grupo
estado islámico que se estableció en
afganistán en 2015 hizo de ellos uno de
sus blancos
esta mezquita chiita fue el blanco de un
atentado kamikaze hace cuatro años desde
entonces está bajo la protección de
guardias armados las 24 horas del día
cómo está la situación todo bien por
ahora ha visto algo sospechoso gracias a
dios no pero estoy atento contamos con
cinco guardias armados y una mujer que
registra a las mujeres en la entrada
todos los guardas son financiados por el
gobierno salvo uno que es financiado por
los feligreses
el imán nos conduce al interior
cuando una banda
la historia de los a sara está plagada
de exacciones como el asesinato de miles
de ellos bajo el régimen talibán desde
2015 el grupo estado islámico nos ha
señalado como blanco muchas
desafortunadamente creo que los chiítas
están viviendo el periodo más difícil de
su historia para nosotros no puede ser
peor y más peligroso las mezquitas y las
escuelas religiosas no son seguras las
ciudades y los bazares tampoco no hay
seguridad
regreso a pakistán detrás de estos muros
se encuentran a sara town uno de los
enclaves de la ciudad donde vive una
parte de los 600.000 miembros de la
comunidad azara
el enclave parece una zona militarizada
estos paramilitares inspeccionan cada
vehículo que se presenta en la entrada
un barrio cortado del resto de la ciudad
como un ghetto étnico que aísla aún más
a la población a sara documento de
identidad
perfecto siga
aquí vive alba y akal
nos reunimos con el militante en su
domicilio vive con sus padres
no
vivimos confinados hay puestos de
control alrededor de la ciudad la gente
no puede reunirse con nosotros
abiertamente en especial con los
pastunes los baluchis los cristianos si
tratan de ingresar a la zona son
arrestados por los paramilitares que les
piden probar su identidad tenemos la
sensación de que hay un cantón militar
donde vivimos
paterno vino pakistán cuando el rey
afgano
rayman masacró a miles de cazar tuvieron
para refugiarse aquí fue hace 150 años
cada vez que estoy solo me quejo ante
mis ancestros preguntándoles por qué se
instalaron en este país habrían podido
ir al españa testigo o ir a irán allá no
seríamos víctimas de ataques
tengo cinco hijos que dios los proteja
esta es la cat y éste sada cat ambos se
fueron al extranjero
aquí había asesinatos selectivos a los
azar a los asesinaban todos los días los
enviamos al extranjero uno de ellos
tenía 16 años
el otro 18 no sé cuándo podré volver a
ver a mis hijos
carbap jacques attali sale muy poco del
enclave
enseña inglés en un establecimiento
ubicado entre estos muros
hoy
hoy hablaremos de la violencia y quién
produce la violencia
los extremistas
la etnia hazara reputada liberal en este
país conservador envía masivamente a las
niñas a la escuela
en educación es todo lo que tenemos
porque la educación hace de su vida una
vida más ilustrada y mejor siempre les
digo a mis estudiantes que cada túnel
oscuro tiene una salida luminosa cada
día es un día
pero para estos estudiantes no siempre
es fácil ver la luz
la gente tiene menos consideración por
nosotros que por las otras etnias cada
vez que vamos a administraciones para
obtener un pasaporte o un documento de
identidad incluso si respetamos todos
los requisitos estos funcionarios nos
discriminan y los procesos toman más
tiempo para nosotros
a unos cuantos metros del enclave en el
barrio pastor de la ciudad algunos no
han dudado en escribir lo que piensan en
los muros ningunas áreas de aventura por
aquí
[Música]
en afganistán nos adentramos en azara
heart literalmente el país de los azares
este amplio territorio está ubicado en
el centro del país
aquí la provincia rural de daykundi una
de las más aisladas y más pobres aquí
las mujeres aprovechan también cierto
progresismo social de hecho una mujer
estaba a la cabeza de la asamblea
provincial
la seguridad de la capital provincial es
muy buena
soy la jefa de la asamblea provincial la
no cuenta ni con policía ni cuarta
espaldas para protegerme puedo
interactuar libremente con la gente la
mayoría de la provincia no tiene
problemas de seguridad pero la situación
es diferente en algunos distritos y
estos vendedores que se aprovisionan en
kabul lo saben muy bien
hola hi hagi cyrus como estas como en
los negocios
no muy bien ha escuchado algo sobre la
seguridad fuera de la capital los
talibán cobran impuestos en la carretera
en el distrito de jal gris los
conductores deben pagar no tienen
elección pagan unos 20 o 30 dólares yo
atara este oasis de paz vecino de una
provincia disputada por los talibán con
no sé violencias desde hace dos años
este representante de un distrito del
sur de la provincia vino a relatar sus
inquietudes a lo largo de estos cuatro o
cinco últimos años más de 150 civiles
así como miembros de las fuerzas de
seguridad local han sido mártires fueron
asesinados por los talibán al qaeda y el
estado islámico escuché que la policía
local no cuenta con nada en los puestos
de control no la cubren y no cuenta con
suficiente munición no cuenta con
transporte adecuado que podemos hacer se
ha quejado
en otros lugares del país la policía
está equipada la tratan bien
aquí no ocurre lo mismo
el distrito de pato es la línea de
frente donde se juega la seguridad de la
capital provincial gracias a para todo
el resto de la provincia de daykundi
está segura hemos ido varias veces a
pedir ayuda ante el gobierno central
pero nadie nos escucha la comunidad a
zara solo obtuvo los mismos derechos con
la constitución afgana de 2004 pero la
minoría chií está subrepresentada en las
instituciones se siente desdeñada por el
gobierno de kabul
agricultores como asadullah kan
decidieron defenderse solos frente a las
incursiones de los talibán hace algunos
años dirigía una milicia de autodefensa
para repeler a los talibán que
destruyeron su propiedad
esta es mi casa tenía 20 hectáreas de
tierra tenía toneladas de cosecha de
trigo y maíz tenía almendros manzanos y
granados a más no poder
mire hoy en día cómo está todo lo
destruyeron
a sus 72 años asadullah kan quiere
retomar las armas
debemos luchar se que estoy viejo soy
diabético pero estoy obligado o muero o
recupero mi propiedad quinientos
agricultores como yo están listos a
seguirme si el gobierno nos da armas y
salario
decide finalmente ir a kabul para
presentarle su solicitud a las
autoridades
no obtendrá respuesta
en la provincia vecina de bamiyán los
azara tiemblan hace cuatro meses no
lejos de los ilustres dudas dinamitados
veinte años atrás tuvo lugar un doble
atentado
sin embargo hay negociaciones de paz sin
cursor para ponerle fin a la guerra que
no da tregua
[Música]
gracias por acompañarnos una vez más en
esta emisión de reporteros recuerde que
puede ingresar a nuestra página web más
24 punto com para ver esta emisión y las
anteriores hasta la próxima semana
[Música]